you know there was a magic when we were
together that we would all love to feel
again Nick we know you're a mega celeb
but save some fans for the rest of your
brothers sure you're a super talented
star but so we're joing kevin we think
we speak for everyone when we say that
we are so excited about your new
happiness begins tour we know going on
tour with siblings can be a little
challenging luckily you guys came up
with some pretty strict rules that you
must follow on the road even pop stars
have to follow the rules the Jonas
Brothers are no exception we got the
lowdown on the strange rules the Jonas
Brothers must follow on their new tour
watch until the end for the most
surprising pre-show ritual ever want to
do something awesome again together
bodyguards there is a time when the
Jonas Brothers didn't need bodyguards
but then an incident happened that
changed the game forever
they were backstage on a school tour
they didn't have any security or a
bodyguard at the time they were prepping
for the show when suddenly the doors
burst open and a bunch of girls rushed
Kevin and his bandmates Kevin said he
was attacked by at least 15 girls it was
so scary they decided it was best to
hire a bodyguard after that family time
according to TMZ Nick Joe and Kevin are
traveling with their wives Priyanka
Chopra Danielle Jonas and sophie Turner
they posed in front of a Jay sisters
backdrop in Miami for the kickoff of the
tour later they boarded the Donis
brothers jet with their furry family
members to travel to the next city on
the tour those puppies are adorable the
Jonas Brothers made it a rule to travel
with their families because family time
is a top priority matching outfits one
roll the Jonas Brothers must stick with
is wearing matching coordinated outfits
at every show style castor wrote that
they're onstage outfits are a reflection
of their maturity they're not teenagers
anymore after all they were wearing
suits on stage but each suit is their
individual signature color Nick looks
sharp in his tangerine colored suit
kevin is channeling prints in his purple
suit and Joe is looking like royalty in
that deep blue color this fashion role
is getting the big thumbs up from bands
social media do you guys remember the
Jonas Brothers social media blackout
fans were freaking out wondering if this
meant they were gone for good or
eventually reuniting for a tour now
their suspicions are confirmed
and their social media accounts are on
fire they are posting about every
performance in every city and they're
even retweeting devoted fan posts who
knew that a blackout could cause so much
hype that's more of a strategy than a
rule but it's totally working always
travel by private jet the Jonas Brothers
learned a thing or two from their last
major tour one important rule they've
adopted is traveling in style by private
jet not only does it allow for their
families to travel comfortably with them
but it also provides a sanctuary for a
much-needed rest between venues they
need to take care of themselves while on
tour so they don't burn out like they
have in the past they like to have a
good time on the Jets like when they
celebrated Nick's 30th birthday above
the clouds not a bad way to party
toothbrush many stars will have riders
in their contracts insisting the venue
where they're performing provides
certain items and amenities some stars
asked for outrageous things like a bowl
full of green M&Ms only no other colors
the Nick Jonas only has one item that he
always asks for it's the most important
item for his backstage preparations he
shared that he always puts a toothbrush
on his writer so now we know how
important oral hygiene is to Nick you
know it's a major rule if it's in his
contract don't listen to the critics the
Jonas Brothers opened up to dr. Phil on
his podcast they discussed the things
they are doing differently this time
around with their new album and tour one
strict rule they implemented is to
ignore the harsh words of haters and
critics they said that in the past
letting all of that negativity in really
took a toll on their creativity and when
their creativity is suffering their
relationships with each other begin to
suffer as well it caused the downward
Spile that they hope to avoid in the
future communication another rule the
Jonas Brothers insisted on its
communication they told dr. Phil that a
major problem in the past was a lack of
communication between the three brothers
they would just follow things up and not
talk about it when things bothered them
now they insist on talking it out if
there are any issues big or small
this helps them squash any possible
discord among the group and keeps them
supporting each other through it all
stay grounded stick together when the
Jonas Brothers parted ways they really
missed each other but they needed some
time apart to heal
during that time apart they realized how
important they are to each other now
they have made a vow to stay grounded
and stick together they know that the
every-man-for-himself approach just
didn't work out for them so they're
doing things differently this time
around pre-show rituals the Jonas
Brothers posted a funny pre-show ritual
that had fans laughing out loud joe said
he took some pre-show rituals from dnce
that he does during the current tour
with Nick and Kevin these rituals
consist of screaming and slapping each
other's faces that sounds about right
for a group of brothers we're glad to
see that they haven't lost their sense
of humor which Jonah's brother is your
favorite and why tell us in the comments
section be sure to subscribe to the
things channel to be the first to see
our latest videos and click the thumbs
up button while you're at it thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]